we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 830
4750 uh who's on the line name in town
hello David I this is timmy from benicia
California pleasure to have you on
what's on your mind today um I would
like just to bring awareness um this
youtuber the Pharaoh he makes videos
criticizing Islam the Prophet Muhammad
and etc but he lives in Egypt and the
Egyptian government is aware that he has
committed blasphemy which in Egypt is a
15 years sentence he's committed
blasphemy multiple times alright and
well I've not heard of it uh I will I
will look into it I cannot vouch for
what you're saying but I am certainly
interested in learning more i'm just not
familiar with this they have a charity
set up by his friends um you can find it
on my twitter @ YT do am i an us um he's
already raised eight thousand dollars
Wow enter and exit be kind xscape Egypt
so he doesn't have to serve a life
sentence yeah that sounds like uh a
worthwhile cause I would also want to
avoid serving a life sentence for uh
blogging and and stating my opinion I I
will look into the story I'm not
familiar with it but I will check it out
thanks for bringing bringing it to our
attention thank you David all right
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / tdps the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s